step number one have a goal make it
specific make sure you know the rules of
the game you're playing make sure you
know what a win looks like in fact that
may be the most important question that
you could ask yourself the most pointed
thing that you can determine in your
life is to know what does it look like
to win once you know what it looks like
to win then you can work backwards then
you can figure out what you need to do
to score then you can figure out the
skills that you're going to need in
order to get great in order to go out
and dominate in order to be better than
anyone that has ever come before you but
to do that you've got to know what your
goal is and once you have that as Dale
Carnegie said if you want to conquer
fear don't sit home and think about it
go out and get busy so now you have your
goal now you're telling people what
you're going to do now you're telling
yourself who you're going to become and
it is terrifying to
how people can pacify themselves with a
sense of accomplishment simply by having
a goal so let me tell you right now the
thing that separates the people who
Dream from the people who execute is a
willingness to act and at the end of the
day nothing is going to stop you not
fear not inability not inadequacy the
only thing that will stop you is failing
to start you've got to find a way to get
yourself going you've got to find a way
to take that desire that interest in you
and turn it into a raging Inferno
something that's going to get you moving
and going ahead that will trample
everything in its path once you're able
to do that nothing and I mean nothing
we'll be able to stop
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Tom bill you and my take on his top 10
will
's enjoy
rule number two connect to your purpose
once you accept
that the thing that separates you from
the rest of the animal kingdom
is an unimaginable ability to become
you have an unimaginable ability to
become something
in 2014 private companies averaged eight
percent annual growth
after I went into my partners and I said
I quit
and I'm gonna go do something that makes
me feel alive they were totally shocked
and I got all the way to my house and I
was on the phone with my wife I did it I
had been unhappy for so long
and I said I did it I told him I quit I
gave back the equity here I am and I'm
pulling into the driveway at my house
and my phone rings
I miss my partners
they say come out to dinner with us
out of respect and love I went out to
dinner with them
and they said the now famous words
we could do this without you
but we don't want to
and that gave me what I needed to
connect to something other than money
it reminded me of the Brotherhood it
reminded me that I had fallen in love
with these guys as human beings that
there was something more than money
there was something more than being a
clever marketer
that I remembered for a second who I am
the things that make me unique that I
have a desire to connect that I actually
enjoy communities that I'm not a guy
with a Killer Instinct I'm not
interested in stepping on my cons my
competitors next this is not how I'm
wired I'm wired to build something I'm
wired to see people shine I love seeing
other people win I think it's incredible
now that doesn't mean that I don't want
to win I want to win at the absolute
highest level I want to be the greatest
of all time
I want more people to write about me
going to Mars because they're terrified
to try to match my intros
I want that right and I hope each and
every one of you wants to play at that
level I hope each and every one of you
looks at the greatest of all time and
says if I'm willing to break myself and
have to get there I could do it
but being honest with who you are being
honest that if there's something else
that you want to bring to the table that
you find a way to do that and so I said
guys I will come back and work with you
on one condition
I will never
prioritize money again
my highest value in business is
camaraderie and at the time that was
sacrilege we had made a pact with each
there was three of us the three of us
had made an actual pact that we would do
whatever it took to make our technology
company more profitable and if that
meant skipping a family vacation if that
meant waking up at 2 A.M on a Saturday
to meet and brainstorm we did it both of
those stories are real we did things
like that I would go away with my wife
for Christmas to see her family in
London and I would literally take a
camera with me so I could watch
the company
back in La I've never switched off I
didn't take days off I was working no
matter where I was I was working seven
days a week I didn't take a real
vacation meaning that I wasn't actually
working while we were on it for six and
a half years rule number three overcome
a fixed mindset here is a reality no
matter how successful the person is that
you're looking at and wishing you could
be like them and thinking that they have
everything all figured out the one thing
that I can promise you is that all of us
struggle on the inside that is just a
reality of The Human Condition once you
understand that that is a reality that
that's just a part of the human
condition then you can begin to ideally
let yourself off the hook and that
you're not spending a lot of time
um stuck there but to give you a
specific example from my life the
biggest one the most harrowing one that
I went through was in film school so uh
to cut a very long story short I went to
film School believe believed that I had
innate talent I went into film school
with a fixed mindset I did very well at
the beginning of film school and that
all to me felt like it was proof that I
was right that I was naturally gifted
that I was a born Storyteller and that I
was going to go and have an illustrious
career and I actually went through a
fascinating period in film school where
I was both terrified that secretly I
wasn't good enough and but at the same
time actually believed that I was
naturally gifted and this is what I was
meant to do and every bit of feedback
that I got in either direction was
it made me believe to the core of my
being that it was true so when I would
do something poorly I would think see
that part of me that was convinced that
I actually don't have talent you were
right and then I would do something well
and the part of me that believed that
was like see I knew it you were born for
this and it all came crashing down as I
worked my way up the ranks at USC Film
School
um only four people are chosen to direct
what's known as the senior thesis film
or a 480. and I was one of the four
people picked and I was like see I knew
it man I'm born for this of course I got
picked to do one of the senior thesis
films that just makes sense I'm I'm that
good and I thought okay cool the thing
that makes the thesis film so important
is the film School pays your budget to
make this film so at a time where
there's no YouTube there's no iPhones
like filming is an expensive Endeavor
here you've got somebody that's paying
for it and that becomes your calling
card to the industry so George Lucas
famously made one of these films and
obviously we know how his career ended
up working out and they showed us his
480 by the way and it was amazing it was
amazing and so you could see that here
was this gifted filmmaker and so I have
that in my head like look at George
Lucas this film's absolutely brilliant
he's gone on to have this brilliant
career I'm gonna make an equally
brilliant film or maybe a little more
brilliant and then I'm gonna go become
the next Lucas or the next Spielberg and
I'm going to take that film and get my
three picture deal
and I proceeded to
runs smack Bang into one immutable truth
and that was that I wasn't a talented
filmmaker
and I don't say that to be humble I say
that out of truth because I didn't have
the skill set to make a good film once
the level of complexity had gone beyond
a certain level so I had thrived in
these really short really simple films
and then once you're talking actors and
dialogue and you know the things that
would come close to what we would
recognize as a normal film uh I had no
idea what I was doing and
try and try as I might I couldn't figure
out how to make the film come out well
and it didn't come out well and I was
mortified and I was embarrassed and I
never wanted anybody to see that film
and I was really and truly devastated so
I want you to imagine your whole life so
what I graduated at like 22. so from 12
to 22
all I knew was I wanted to be a
filmmaker and my whole life was moving
towards that and it looked like I had
the natural gift and of course if you're
going to be an artist you're either born
with it or you're not right that's all
anybody said I can't express enough in
the 80s and 90s when I grew up when
people talked about art you either had
it or you didn't and that was that there
was no sense of growth mindset Carol
dweck had not written the book yet and
so it wasn't even like I knew there was
a growth mindset and a fixed mindset I
just knew you're either born with it or
you're not
the great news was I was born with it
here we go it's going to be amazing and
then boom I can't do it and I realize oh
my God I wasn't born with anything I
don't know how to do this there is a
tremendous amount of process to this art
and I don't know that at all but of
course as I'm in the middle of it I just
think my world has come crashing down
I'm not gifted I will never be gifted
and therefore I will never be a
filmmaker I will never make anything of
myself and just it was a downward spiral
of epic proportions
and at the height of that I would go
home from my dead-end job and I would
lay
face down on the carpet because I
couldn't afford furniture and
literally just sit there I can still
feel
that cheap nylon carpet and the way that
it felt on my face as I laid there
thinking well
my life is effectively over certainly
the
my life that was working towards a dream
is over
and
now it's just about finding a way to be
the smartest person in the room and if
that means that I have to go and work a
dead-end job to be the smartest person
in the room then that's what I'll do and
so I used to go and interview for jobs
having nothing to do with film
because I felt totally broken and
my goal was to at some point in the
interview have the interviewer say
you're so smart why are you interviewing
for this role and because I had a fixed
mindset and I so needed that praise from
the outside I was putting myself in
these super weird and useless positions
just to get that little nugget of oh my
God like you're so smart
and I had to put myself in sort of worse
and worse company to get to that point
and
finally and I don't remember what it was
that
led me to this idea of brain plasticity
but somewhere in the depths of my
despair I realized
can we get better maybe we can and so I
started reading about the brain
and that started to plant seeds in my
mind that maybe brain plasticity was
real and maybe I could get better and
just because I wasn't good at film today
maybe I could get better at film down
the road and I ended up getting a job
teaching film because remember those
that can do those that can't teach so I
felt like okay well I can teach this
even if I can't do it and then so
between reading about the brain and
realizing wait a second
if I work at this thing I actually get
better my brain actually changes and I
become better at something and
given you know having gone through
however many years of schooling I'd been
through I started thinking about like
wait a second you would come into any
class and the funny thing is as a kid I
remember every grade just being
absolutely terrified that well I did
okay at being a fourth grader but Mom
I'm going to get devastated as a fifth
grader I don't know what I'm doing and
no matter how many times my mom would
console me and say remember they're
going to teach you how to learn the
things that a fifth grader needs to know
they don't expect you to already know it
it just wouldn't sink in and so I was
sort of back in that moment of you know
I don't know how to do this
but maybe
my mom is right maybe the
neuroscientists are right and maybe I
can learn
to become that thing I want to become I
start teaching film and as I'm teaching
it I realize wait I'm helping my
students become better filmmakers so if
I can help them become better filmmakers
and brain plasticity is really true then
I could get better as a filmmaker myself
and that that realization changed the
rest of my life and this is why I am so
obsessed with the idea of
a growth mindset and brain plasticity
because the biology backs it up and once
you understand it's what I call the only
belief that matters the only belief that
matters is that if you put time and
energy
into getting better at something you'll
actually get better rule number four
have Clarity have very clear goals it
always freaks me out most people stop at
the first sort of vague notion of what
they want to do I'm going to punch
myself in the mouth if somebody comes up
to me again and says I want to help
people
that's rad that comes from a beautiful
place like I totally get it but that's
like coming to me and saying I want to
win an Olympic gold medal awesome winter
or summer
fantastic swimming or tennis
swimming excellent
backstroke freestyle like at some point
it's got to get so specific because you
have to know what skills you need to
acquire you have to work backwards from
the goal and the goal has to be hyper
specific so if boredom is the number one
killer of entrepreneurs that they're not
able to make it through the next one is
they don't have clear goals and the
worst part is they think they do
that's the part that terrifies me the
worst part is they think they do
until you know exactly what your mission
is and exactly what your business model
is and what problem you solve what very
concrete problem that people are
freaking out to have solved until you do
that you don't have the necessary
ingredients to build your business all
right don't be romantic be pragmatic
look at the data the data will tell you
what to kill the data will tell you
what's working and what's not
this was the single best piece of advice
that was ever given to me and I ignored
it for three years I'm so embarrassed by
that that I always make sure any talk I
give people hear this
know more about your product service
industry whatever than anyone else
than anyone else
if you guys have ever seen my interview
show
the reason that it's doing as well as
it's doing is I know more about the
guest one guest actually said this I
know more about the guest than their
mother
I just put in more work than their
mother
that's the truth
I go out and I research and I read
everything and I watch every video that
I can and so I know so much about that
person I know I'm going to give a
different interview than anyone has ever
given before because nobody's done that
level of research not only does it Blow
the guest away and totally endear them
to me
but it gets us to the point where we can
give an interview that has unique value
so know more about what you're doing
than anyone else in the world and grind
baby grind for two years for two years
that's what I look like every day
hairnet lab coat gloves
put in the work
put in the work and this is where the
rubber meets the road this is where
you're really going to separate the
people that are entrepreneurs from the
people that are real entrepreneurs
you've got to want to grind you've got
to learn to love that you've got to
learn to love to put in the work to be
proud of yourself that you showed up and
put in the work to be proud of yourself
that you taught yourself how to suffer
to be proud of yourself that you're
developing a mindset where you believe I
can do anything I set my mind to and by
the way
once you believe
that you can do anything you set your
mind to without limitation how you spend
your time
becomes a spiritual consideration
how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration because you
could be doing something if you want to
end Hunger and hunger what's stopping
you Bill Gates is actually going to end
malaria he's going to do it because he
had the tenacity to generate the
resources and because he has a mind that
allows him to work on the infrastructure
and figure out how to actually solve
that problem do not under any
circumstances make Bill Gates or anyone
else extraordinary to let yourself off
the hook
don't do it don't sell yourself short
and this is where I see people go wrong
all the time they look at somebody who's
amazing
and they say Well they're just naturally
gifted
I could never do that
you couldn't do it because you believe
you can't and because you believe you
can't you don't start putting in the
work
Michael Jordan got cut from his high
school basketball team
he wasn't exactly showing all the
promise in the world my own mother when
I left for college quietly assumed I was
going to fail and didn't admit that for
years
I showed no early signs of promise
I actually have a version of this talk
where I show photos from my childhood
and people like yeah you just look
stupid
and it's true I used to dress like a
clown and I mean that almost literally
so my waist was size 36 and I wore a
size 54 pants
I wore literal Jester hats I had one of
those big chains that connected to my
belt I had shoulder length hair I did
not exactly look the part and I didn't
take myself seriously
it really is a game of transformation it
really is a game of understanding that
you can become something so even though
I didn't start with the requisite skills
even though I wasn't a born entrepreneur
which is why I start this tale with that
even though I wasn't a born entrepreneur
I could acquire and did acquire the
skills that were needed to execute
it is a very long road
that leads you here
right now
most entrepreneurs in the world are
thinking about one thing
winning a championship ring also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five learn to fail
forward to make progress and to fail
forward to really figure out when you
make this catastrophic error
you have to conceptualize it in the
right way so when you're trying
something recognize that as a hypothesis
so number one is to recognize I have a
goal my goal is over there I'm here
there's a gap between my goal and I I
need to know what that Gap is I need to
understand it I need to know what the
impediment is I need to recognize why if
I just keep doing the thing that I'm
doing now why am I not going to get
where I'm going okay so first you have
to identify that now once you identify
that then it becomes a question of what
is your best guess which we will call it
which is called a hypothesis so you make
that hypothesis which again is just your
best guess as to what you would need to
do it's very important this isn't
thinking we're not going to live in the
abstract that when we finish this it's
going to tell us to do something so what
would I need to do
in order to overcome the obstacle that
stands between me and my goal if your
major goal is like way down the road
you're going to have to break it down
into smaller goals and so this goal with
my next 15 minutes is how I tell people
to think of it when you understand your
goal clearly enough and you understand
the impediments clearly enough you know
exactly what you should be doing with
the next 15 minutes okay that's the
level of clarity that you need so okay
cool
I've identified this what the thing is
that I believe I need to do it's a guess
don't wait for lightning to strike don't
wait for anything to be self-evident
you have a best guess as to what you
should do with the next 15 minutes and
then your 15-minute stack up to your
best guess you know over uh a week or a
month or a quarter you know whatever
however big that project is
then you're going to do that thing
so I have a hypothesis on what would be
the most efficient way most effective
way for me to overcome this obstacle and
then I'm going to do that thing and that
thing is either going to work or it's
not and if it works amazing did it work
as well as it could have if not and I
have to do this it's something I have to
do again then refine and do it again if
it did then what's my next obstacle and
I'm going to do that one now eventually
you're going to do something and it
doesn't work it either you stood still
or you made so little progress as to be
Unworthy of Celebration or maybe you
even move backwards maybe this is that
moment where you totally embarrass
yourself maybe this is something that
happened out in public and now you look
like a total ass and in that moment you
need to go okay
why did this not work okay so this is
where we analyze the data now the key to
analyzing the data is before you run
this experiment you need to say what
success looks like so all right if I
think here's my best guess as to what I
need to do to overcome this problem
and here is what success will look like
so let me give you an example
we had a hypothesis I still can't
believe that this is true but it is we
had a hypothesis here on our YouTube
channel that if we put
guests uh if we took a photo of them or
pulled a screenshot from the episode
where they're doing something with their
hands that the click rate will go up and
that the click rate will positively
impact our monetized views okay so
that's our hypothesis we test it
I still can't believe this is true but
it works and it doesn't just work most
of the time it works almost all of the
time now nothing is you never have one
blanket statement where it truly works
for everything but I'm talking north of
95 so hey we have this hypothesis it
worked we did it now the number of times
where we had a hypothesis hey uh
should put make the text white with a
um drop shadow we tried it and that
didn't work and it's like wow I can't
believe that didn't work it looks so
much better than black text
but it keeps losing over and over and
over so in that moment it's like okay
well I really thought this was gonna
work but it didn't work and you try
something else now when it's something
where there's emotion involved that gets
harder for people to get clear on what
the data is and that's why you have to
have a uh a very clear understanding of
what success looks like rule number six
earn credibility now let's talk about
the more important part which is earning
credibility with yourself
this was one of the big breakthroughs in
my life was realizing that if I said I
was going to do something
and I wanted to give up on it I would
think about well if I position it this
way if I move this way if I kind of hide
this from that person and sweep this
under the rug over here then I can still
manage other people's
beliefs about who I am
and as long as other people think that
I'm cool I'm good I'm talented I'm smart
whatever then I'm good and what I
realized is a that only works fifty
percent of the time so 50 of the moves
that you make to try to
um manage your persona
50 of the time it works the other fifty
percent of the time though people see
through it and then you begin to earn
the reputation of being a [ __ ]
artist so what I realized was okay not
only does it not work as well externally
as I think but it doesn't matter what
the outside world thinks if I don't
think positively of myself so that
became my obsession is understanding
credibility is most important when
you're talking about self-credibility
and how we earn credibility with
ourselves is by saying I'm going to do
this thing and then doing it and then
you just keep inching that out farther
and farther and farther until you get to
the point where you show up for yourself
in the most extreme and difficult of
circumstances so I'll tell you guys a
story
um at my old house I used to have this
painting of the Michael Jordan Flu Game
hanging above my fireplace and that was
so inspiring to me and I always said I
put that up there to remind myself of
what I'm capable of and how I would
react if I were put in a championship
game situation and then lo and behold
the Flash Forward probably a year later
and I actually get the flu and I have a
double episode the next day and I
remember I had a fever I was rocked I
could barely stand up I it was really
miserable and I had to do all the prep
the day before for the episodes
and I was like I actually don't know if
I'm going to be able to make it through
this like it it that's how sick I was
it's one of the sickest I've ever been
rule number seven develop grit if grit
is as important as we say it is
sustained interest over time that's
really what grit is
and a lot of people talk about in fact
the title of my speech is supposed to be
about how you develop a passion which we
will talk about in a little bit but this
is going to be one of those things when
you have passion one of the things that
comes out of that is you've got the
ability to sustain your interest over
time do the hard things
do the hard things I can't emphasize
that one enough
put yourself in uncomfortable situations
just to find the mental tactics that
you're going to need to deal with the
hard things it's getting those tactics
who knows the Stanford marshmallow test
all right for those of you that don't
this is one of the most breathtaking
examples of The Human Condition in the
Stanford marshmallow test they bring in
another five or six years old they bring
them in and the person in the white lab
coat says here's a marshmallow I'm gonna
go out of the room for a minute I'll be
back in just a few minutes if you wait
till I come back I'll give you a second
marshmallow so essentially double your
money
not bad now what the kid doesn't know is
the researcher is never coming back and
all they want to know is how long will
you wait before you eat the marshmallow
some kids have literally gobbled it up
before they even get to the door
other kids are like singing to
themselves putting their head down
getting up dancing around the room some
of them bite like the underside and try
to put it back so you can't see
and here's what's scary
they followed those kids for 25 years
and based solely on the length of time
they were able to wait before they ate
the marshmallow predicted their level of
success in school
predicted their level of success in the
job market the people who waited the
longest got into the best schools got
the best grades went on to have the
highest paying jobs
just your ability to delay gratification
your ability to find tactics that work
to get your mind off something
there's no greater control than control
over oneself
anybody here ever done a three-day water
only fast not intermittent fasting
three days
do it you will learn something about
yourself and it will be profound and
what you're going to learn is that your
body is manipulative
and I did a three-day fast just a couple
weeks ago
and I had the flu right before so there
were cough drops laying around
and every time I walk by those cough
drops
my brain was like eat one
and I was like like
you know I'm fasting
and I literally couldn't believe like
how consistently every time I walk by
those damn cough drops that my body like
gave me this really intense impulse
and that's when I realized like the
notion that there are multiple voices in
your head by the way is very very real
and I will give you one quick example
who knows what the corpus callosum is
all right the corpus callosum is the
thick bit of tissue that connects the
left and right hemisphere of your brain
If you sever that you will get people
that have literal multiple personalities
one in the right one on the left some of
the most intriguing stuff is one of them
will be devoutly religious and the other
will be devoutly atheist in the same
brain and you can talk to them
differently
absolutely crazy
but the multiple voices notion is real
there are multiple
factions if you will pieces that your
brain is broken up into and by the way
you have the equivalent of a cat's brain
in neurons just in your digestive tract
so the whole notion of gut instinct
think of all the cool cats can do
and you've got that
in your digestive tract neurons
it's literally the same material that
your brain is made out of is in your
digestive tract it's utterly fascinating
so we have all these competing things
that we want
but inside if you think of that
OverWatch that one person that's you
that's meant to say I have goals and I'm
going to act in accordance with my goals
I'm never going to sell out what I want
most for what I want right now I wanted
a cough drop right now but I wanted to
get on the other side of the three-day
fast and say I did it and I wanted that
more
and in learning what your tools and
tactics are so for me I welcome hunger
like an old friend and I literally
people must think I'm schizophrenic
because you'll walk into the room and
I'll literally be like pinching and
poking at my fat going hunger thank you
I'm so glad you made it back it is so
good to see you I'm glad you're here I
know that you're oxidizing my fat and
I'm very grateful for that so thank you
and in doing that I reframe it not as
something that is unwanted or painful
but it's something that is doing exactly
what I want it to do
and learning those mental tactics that's
the game learning those mental tactics
that's the game that's how you're going
to get good at whatever it is you want
to do if you want to start a business
learning how to deal with your employees
is absolutely critical but let me tell
you right now if you lash out
emotionally your employees will lose
respect for you
but it's just like the cough drop moment
now if somebody had seen me walk by the
cough drop they wouldn't know that I had
it literally had to stop myself from
lunging at a cough drop
they didn't know that because I have
control of myself
I've practiced things like that I do
three day fast I do what I call Bright
lines
so I have a bright line
during the week I don't eat my second
meal before 11 30. under any
circumstance
my wife one time brought my food 30
minutes early I Was preparing for an
episode it was so sweet of her
but I don't eat before 11 30 under any
circumstance so the food literally sat
on my lap smelling so good and I was so
hungry and I said hunger thank you so
much for showing up because you're
giving me the opportunity to prove to
myself what a badass I am because I'm
gonna smell how delicious you are
knowing my stomach is grumbling and
tying itself in knots because I want to
eat so badly and I'm not going to
and in those moments you earn
credibility with yourself
I hate working out
absolutely despise it it's why I do it
first thing in the morning
and the reason I hate it the weights are
heavy
and your muscles start burning when you
get into the supposed good reps
so that just seems backwards
so it is not in any way shape or form
fun for me
but I earn credibility with myself
because it is something that I don't
like
I earn credibility with myself showing
up every day and it also reminds me how
much I can transform my body it's very
easy for me to show you my before and
after picture I used to be 60 pounds
heavier it's very easy for me to show
you when I was heavy and then show you
six-pack abs you get it
but what you don't see is the body's
just a reflection of the Mind
what really happened
was I changed my mind and I had garnered
skills I had garnered tactics the things
that allowed me to not eat the coffee
drop were the things that allowed me to
not eat the things that I wanted to not
have a bowl of ice cream to not indulge
in things that are wonderfully delicious
but instead ask myself what are my goals
and then back in with my behaviors rule
number eight be accountable to yourself
I think the reality is you just have to
realize that there's more advantage to
holding yourself accountable all the
time than to
hiding from it not living up to your own
standards it seems like the right answer
to you know let yourself off the hook or
to make promises that you're not
actually prepared to keep because it's
cool or whatever it seems to make sense
in the moment
but going back to that idea of having
credibility with yourself is one of the
most powerful emotions you will ever
feel to respect yourself is
it's one of the the pillars of
self-worth and if you don't have
self-worth
that is a really gnarly place to be and
so
it's very okay
to only make yourself very small
promises in the beginning and then we'll
widen that out slowly over time but that
was how I earned credibility with myself
in the beginning when I didn't have any
when I would say I was going to do
things and then not do them when I would
say I'm going to get out of bed tomorrow
you know really early and then I would
lay in bed for five hours which used to
happen all the time
so I didn't start by saying oh I'm gonna
get shredded or I'm gonna build a big
business it started with I'm gonna go to
the gym not even I'm gonna work out hard
I'm gonna go to the gym and so then I
would go to the gym if I felt like
walking out I would walk out
then as I found okay hey look at that
I'm being consistent I'm going to the
gym every time that I say I'm going to
go to the gym now it's about okay well
can I push it a little harder than I did
last time and then you start doing that
and then it's like well can I set a goal
for myself to be able to lift a certain
amount of weight to look a certain way
to lose a certain amount of fat whatever
it is you want to do if you start
building on that making slightly bigger
demands over time you know maybe you
increment the demand weekly and so it's
like this is what I'm gonna do this week
and then the next week is a little more
all of a sudden a year later it's pretty
extraordinary you've had 52 increments
of improvement which is huge
so realizing that you get this
tremendous benefit from two things one
making what you promise yourself smaller
so that you know you can trust yourself
to do it and then two constantly like
bumping that out a little bit that you
actually get a huge reward so in in that
you have gotten better at something you
have moved towards a goal you have
actually obtained your goals that you
can set over time you can set these
bigger and bigger more audacious goals
and you can actually reach them now when
you know that about yourself you have
that credibility with yourself
you know that you're going to stick to
it now when you set a goal it's like yo
this goal is exciting I'm amped up
because I know that I'm going to follow
through and as long as you've built up
that muscle right the resilience
the ability to push through pain boredom
when you have that and you've built that
resilience that tenacity now all of a
sudden you don't want to not be
accountable to yourself because you want
to feel good about yourself and
you actually want to achieve those goals
man that's like if I could snap my
fingers and give people a gift it would
be to say hey the craziest dream that
you have you can actually make that come
true
the craziest dream that you have you can
actually make come true
that's why accountability is so joyful
rule number nine see Clarity and wise
choices if you want to do something
recognize there's no obstacle holding
you back other than what you choose to
believe and if you want to be miserable
it's going to be there for you and if
you want to be empowered it's there for
you if you want strength it is there for
you it's a decision it's something that
you decide to believe in that you can
get strong and that ultimately is the
ultimate strength to believe that you
can get better to believe that you can
become whatever you want to become so
choose optimism right now choose to let
it fill you choose to feel it to sit in
that Sensation that anything you set
your mind to is possible when you allow
yourself to embody that to believe in no
matter what anybody tells you no matter
how many people tell you that you're
stupid you're a failure that you're
never going to do anything that you are
going to believe in yourself if you can
do that if you can choose that optimism
you can go anywhere
because you realize everything you
needed was in you all along
he was simply choosing to believe you
could execute against it
so have that faith go out and do it and
Rule Number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is know who you
are becoming the reality is if you want
to achieve something great in your life
you've got to be willing to accept who
you really are right now you've got to
know exactly what you're good at and
what you're not and the reason that the
truth is going to piss you off is it's
going to hurt it's going to hurt to
acknowledge that you're not yet who you
want to be it's going to hurt to know
that you're not yet capable of the
things that you want to be capable of
and it's really going to hurt
to know that the things that people say
behind your back the things that they
say to hurt you
that they're actually true
that they're right they have a point you
aren't good at that thing you aren't as
good as you could be you did embarrass
yourself you have fallen down all of
those things are almost certainly true
but when you can look at those things
when you can stare nakedly at your
inadequacies when you can really stop
and not protect yourself with ego but
protect yourself by knowing that you're
going to learn from where you failed
you're going to learn from the places
you've fallen down you're going to learn
your inadequacies so that you can build
something new
the reality is that those who can delay
eating the marshmallow the longest do
the best because you're right delaying
gratification is an absolute superpower
now one of the most extraordinary
experiments was done at Stanford
University it's called the marshmallow
experiment there's a whole book written
on this utterly fascinating they
followed the participants in the study
for like 25 years absolutely incredible
they bring these kids into a room
they give them a marshmallow and they
say Hey you can eat the marshmallow now
if you want but if you wait until I come
back then I'll give you two marshmallows
so it's basically double your money it's
not going to be that long now what the
kid doesn't know is that the researcher
isn't coming back and they just want to
see how long the kid is going to wait
until they eat it they do eventually
come back but they leave them really to
struggle for quite some time and
what they found was the kids that could
come up with games where they're singing
to themselves not looking at the
marshmallow whatever the kids that were
able to delay the gratification the
longest ended up doing the best they got
the best grades they got the highest
paying jobs they had the most successful
relationships now the reason that that
works is in any one moment if you're
just operating around optimizing for
momentary mind States brain States
neurochemical states then you're always
going to be in short-term thinking
you're always going to get short-term
results if however you have this goal
that excites you and is Honorable
and you're able to push through all the
boring stuff and all of that then what
you get is a set of skills that allow
you to do things other people can't do
and as we establish in the last question
if you can do things other people can't
do that is by its very nature success
and you will be rewarded in a way that
other people will not be rewarded
because they can't do the things you do
and as long as the things you do are
valued by Society then you are always
going to do very well
but that ultimately is the key you have
to be able to delay gratification now
for me understanding that that was the
nature of things that if I can delay my
momentary wishes for something longer
term then I could get these very
different results that separated me from
other people and because I'm excited
about what I'm pursuing I use that
excitement as my trick to stay focused
when things get boring and I've said
many times that boredom kills more
entrepreneurs than failure so everyone
will tell you that fear of failures what
stops people and that is a huge deal but
honestly like I think it's the fact that
people don't want the outcome badly
enough to fight through all the boring
painful stuff that you have to go
through to get to the other side to
ultimately be successful so
make sure that you are hyped up on your
goal if you're not then you're not going
to be willing to go through all the
difficult things I like Jordan
Peterson's idea of tell the truth or at
least try not to lie
sometimes
there can be a truth that we leave
unsaid
because this is a momentary interaction
where I would say kindness is the higher
value than pointing out every flaw that
we see or every bit of obnoxious
behavior because at some point it just
spirals into madness to point out every
misstep that somebody is doing and so
when I look at somebody that is
being obnoxious being rude my goal is to
shift their energy
how can I get them back into a place
where they're feeling good they're
feeling warmth they are
in a place where they feel kind right
because most people it isn't that they
are
incapable of kindness and if they are
like imagine how that life would be
somebody who never experiences kindness
Joy warmth connection
that would truly be its own hell
so I'm not going to
worry about pointing out every obnoxious
saying that they're doing and I would
play a game with myself of how much joy
can I spread and
in some ways
you are
leaving a truth unsaid which is that
they're being unkind or obnoxious or
whatever
but by trying to spread kindness you're
not lying
and
especially if you share that value with
me of wanting to just put as much Good
Vibes into the world you can and look
I'm not perfect and there is no doubt
that sometimes people are just like God
damn like I just don't want anything to
do with it
but that doesn't feel like me at my best
me at my best feels like all right cool
can we switch this energy around can we
get them to soften to
feel that human warmth and a bit of
connection and can I
I mean with a smile you will be shocked
how much you can change somebody's
demeanor so that's how I would flip it I
would just see how much joy can I spread
even when people are being problematic
to me now that doesn't mean that I let
people abuse me or anything like that I
don't I imagine you guys can get a
pretty good guess about uh what I'm like
I don't let people walk over me or be a
dick to me or whatever but I find it far
more interesting to try to change
somebody's energy than to get them to go
yeah I am being a
that's just not interesting to me trying
to get them to sort of confess
that they're the problem
I'd much rather hold myself accountable
to like how much sort of emotional
Jujitsu can I do here let's play a game
and let's call this game
what would Tom do
now I want you to ask do you think that
Tom is going to stay in a bad job for
long
no
that's the I'll skip to the last page
and Tom has a bad job uh skip to the
last page tom leaves the job now Tom is
going to be very thoughtful because I
completely understand that this is
largely about yo I have to pay bills hey
Tom nice for you you don't have kids and
you've already been successful so that's
not really helpful for me
now I will say that
joy and fulfillment are the punchline of
life not money not success not adoration
so you are losing losing losing if
you're staying in a job that makes you
unhappy I promise if you have kids and
that's the thing that's really making
this difficult you are bringing that
unhappiness home and so we have a moral
obligation to break that to make sure
that we are pursuing things that are
joyful so that we can show our kids hey
this is how it's done now you're not
stuck at a job there's something that's
making you feel stuck at the job I'm
going to assume for now that it's money
keeping a roof over your loved one's
heads that that to me seems like the
scariest so okay assuming that it's that
remember there are always two levers
lever number one make more money lever
number two need less money okay you can
pull on either lever you want now if you
say up Tom I can't need less money just
we're all we've already cut it all to
the quick you know my kids just need a
certain amount and just is what it is
okay amazing so now we're gonna make
more money awesome how do we go about
doing that first of all let's identify
what we hate about our job because there
might be are there other roles within
that company if it's just the job but
not the company is there somewhere that
we could move in which case we go ask
hey I want this job which pays more
money what would I need to do what skill
set would I need to have what expertise
would I need to demonstrate in order to
get there
and then go do that thing
if it's the company and we just the
company's toxic we can't be there
anymore then I will ask how many resumes
have you sent out in the last 48 hours
if the answer isn't 250 then we've got
some work to do
now let's assume that the answer is 250.
then we have to figure out why aren't we
getting a response do we not have a
skill set that's marketable is our
resume terrible are we not going out to
the right places have we not framed
ourself well
could be any one of those things but we
have to be honest and real and figure
out what we need to do to get out of
this situation but we certainly don't
just accept defeat and go wow this sucks
this is my whole life
nights and weekends is also going to
come to our
help our Aid here so nights and weekends
if you know whoa I just don't have the
skill set that I need to go find another
job then we're going to start building
that skill set
maybe the skill set is interviewing
getting good at interviewing and then
we're going to get good at that but we
are going to find a way out of our
situation and we are going to find a way
out of our situation quickly so do not
accept defeat hold yourself accountable
to the truth to what you need to do to
get out of that situation and then get
out
because as you said our time is truly
limited when people are truly passionate
about what they do you just get a
chemical rush you get the energy you
become more resourceful when someone who
doesn't have passion because they don't
really want to be there anyway they will
give up way easier because they're not
having a good time it's not in them
there's an awesome quote I'm
paraphrasing but you'll get the idea
don't try to change the world unless you
seek change the way a man whose head is
on fire seeks a pond
that is so true like imagine what that
would be like right your head is
literally on fire your ass is going to
find some water you will Mash your head
into the side of a rhino if you have to
to put it out right like you're putting
it out there is an immediacy to that
need that gets humans to do incredible
if you want to change your life you've
got to tap into something that gives you
that same feeling for me it's passion
and for the people that I've seen that
have that passion something is burning
inside of them wow man you can do
incredible stuff now the follow-up I'll
ask my own follow-up question well how
do you find that thing that you're
passionate about since I know that's the
next question that people ask
in you right now is the Ember of
something you don't want to admit to
yourself I promise you
and if you let me interview you long
enough I will get to that thing and you
will resist me trying to get to that
thing for a very long time first you'll
give me a [ __ ] answer first you're
going to tell me that you want to be
happy that's useless I need to know what
makes you happy I need to know how you
plan to be happy
okay when people say generically that
they want to be happy they might as well
tell me that they want a hit of meth
because they're just saying I want a
chemical state
great
it's transient it's going to go away
that's not very useful for you then once
we get past that you want to be happy
you're going to guess at some random
things that make you happy I want to be
around my family all that okay well
let's put that in context you're here
seeking a job or you're asking me a
question about being an entrepreneur and
you're telling me that the thing that
makes you happy is being with your
family I can't help you with that in
fact I'm going to do the exact opposite
if I do my job I'm pulling you all away
from your family all the time I'm trying
to get you to commit so deeply to what
we're trying to accomplish here that
you're going to be absent just from a
physical time perspective and my only
hope is that I light you on fire with so
much passion that I send you back to
your family full of joy optimism and a
vision for you being able to do anything
you want now that's infectious your
family will love you for it and they'll
push you right back into my loving arms
but that's still not the truth that's me
feeding you answers so once we get past
that and we paint that picture we
finally get to I don't know
which is the truth
that lies on top of the better truth
that I'm going after which is that thing
underneath that you never thought you
were able to acknowledge that is the
thing that you really want
and for me it was finally admitting that
I didn't have to wait for my family to
make good choices I could find a way to
trick them into eating healthy once I
honestly accepted that that's what I
wanted that I was not prepared to wait
that I was going to be a Jedi I was
going to walk up to somebody and I was
going to get them to do things that was
quite literally against their will and I
was going to make them want to do it and
it was going to be better for their life
and they were ultimately going to thank
me and I was going to do it without any
Force at all
I was going to do it by understanding
them as a human being by attaching
myself to the things that were already
working for me their biological impulse
to eat something that they crave their
biological impulse to soothe themselves
with food I knew I've got all that I
know those levers are there so now I
just have to do the hard work of making
something that's actually good for them
that has all of those taste Pathways
your brain has evolved to be a thing
and there is a lot rightly so of focus
in the popular Zeitgeist around mindset
about understanding the mind and that is
critically important but so few people
take the time to really understand what
gives birth to the mind which is your
biology and so understanding
your mind within the context of
evolution and the Brain become
critically important and people that uh
don't take the time to distinguish
between the brain and the mind are doing
themselves a disservice I think much of
what they go through is going to be
oh it's going to be surprising is what I
was going to say but the reality is what
people end up getting stuck on is they
confuse feeling with thinking and
the immediacy of feelings the visceral
nature of them there's something about
embedded in the way that we experience
an emotion is this just screaming from
our subconscious that this is real this
is true this is this is like this is it
this is the context everything you need
to know dear mind is contained in this
emotion and
it's really an interesting process that
I I think warrants a lot more thought on
certainly my part uh and probably
Sciences part and for sure
um any of you that are following along
at home uh a big part of what you should
be thinking about
is the Nuance of how all of this comes
into being and how
how emotions are
the great trick that they pull is they
they paint themselves to be self-evident
thank you for letting me think in real
time here this is interesting
emotions feel self-evidently
right I don't even want to say true
because true doesn't capture what's
really going on when I try to talk about
the physics of Being Human a big part of
that is that sense
that my reaction
to this moment to this event
does not strike me as a decision it
strikes me as self-evidently right
because of the things that I feel
and
I'm pretty sure that as we went through
one of the classes I read
um a quote by Thomas Soul which I'm
going to paraphrase and it's
the problem isn't that Timmy doesn't
know how to read the problem isn't even
that Timmy doesn't know how to think the
problem is that Timmy doesn't know what
thinking is he confuses it for feeling
and we feel something
It Feels So self-evidently Right that
this reaction that we're having is not
an echo of biology and context and our
own life experiences in a bazillion
decisions about what to believe that we
have made it feels self-evidently the
only
logical way to react to this set of
circumstances and that is what leads
people to spiral because people have
different reactions they both think they
are self-evidently right and people
spiral and so now re-anchoring you guys
back around this idea of no no you have
a goal
the only thing that matters is Will
reacting the way that you're reacting
take you towards that goal and if we can
all Embrace this idea of fulfillment
that fulfillment is the goal having a
positive emotional state that is
resilient to the ups and downs of life
because we have self-respect self-worth
we're elevating ourselves and proving
ourselves and elevating improving those
around us
if that's our goal and we can all buy
into that now we have a steering
mechanism and this is the thing that's
crazy making for me in this you know
um cultural upheaval that we're living
through right now which is people don't
agree on what the goal is and when you
don't agree on what the goal is now you
have what Lisa and I call a collision of
values when you have a collision of
values either talk about the Collision
of values or shut the [ __ ] up like
legitimately those are your two options
because option one
let's talk about the Collision of values
and like what should be the goal
fruitful things can come out of that
arguing about the T as Lisa and I call
it the biggest argument we ever had was
over a cup of tea now you can imagine
that doesn't make any sense how could
you ever get in a fight that large over
a cup of tea the answer is you can't but
you can get in an argument that big
about a collision of values which then
attacks your sense of self identity
there's this incongruous thing where
your reaction feels self-evidently
correct
and yet this person is acting in a crazy
way because the way that I feel that is
self-evidently correct there's no need
to even question it it is obviously
right
now
you get these massive fireworks because
the other person is thinking the exact
same thing
they feel self-evidently correct because
they have all these emotions that are
kicked up by their biology that is
kicked up by millions of years of
evolution misinterpreted through this
lens that we live in called life
in a modern context completely removed
from the evolutionary soup
that our brains marinated in
our brains marinated in as they were
formed
how all of a sudden people cannot allow
themselves to conceive that oh this
emotion was a choice
which I have made somewhere through a
string of the gazillion little moments
that led up to right now in this moment
all of those decisions have formed a set
of values and those values are
essentially invisible to me because I
have mistaken them for truth therefore
my values become water right to the fish
fish is the last one to know what water
is it's just it permeates everything in
their world it just is it's like us and
heir
right that actually had to be discovered
imagine
the
hundreds of thousands of years like
really think about how long where you've
got human level cognition as we think of
it today
and yet there's no concept of
I'm in this thing
it just
you're here
and values become that water
you don't even think about them you
don't think that they govern essentially
every aspect of your life
and yet they do and the failure to
recognize that my values are not
objectively real they are simply choices
that I have made invisibly based on all
these emotions that I've gotten which
were kicked up to me by evolution
I don't understand them I don't
understand what drives them but they
feel self-evidently true therefore I go
with them therefore however I feel I
confuse with thinking and I think I've
thought through the problem I think I
have articulated what my goal is and how
I'm going to get there but the reality
is I've just been feeling this whole
time
and Chaos ensues where should a person
start with improving their self-care if
they have low self-esteem do you think
leveraging one can directly improve the
other okay
you've really got two issues here
but they are inextricably linked
you've got biology you've got psychology
the self-care is largely going to be a
question of biology getting the sleep
eating a diet that
at a cellular level is serving us at a
microbiome level is helping us at a
cognition level is helping us right
setting us up for Success meditating
making sure that we get that background
Stress and Anxiety radiation down to
zero
um huge in terms of getting you into a
calm and creative space so that you can
think through difficult problems
all of these things are what you're
going to need to do if you want to do
well in your life now
self-esteem is a whole other issue
self-esteem has everything to do with
what you think about yourself when
you're by yourself now you have to earn
your way to that
and so the key to earning your way to
that is to figure out what is your value
system what do you value what do you
think is the way that people should be
spending their time and their energies
and then are you doing things in
accordance with that and then there are
things that are baked in that are innate
so there are these in a drivers given to
us by Evolution uh hard work the desire
to contribute to the group meaning and
purpose deep connection with other
people that we love okay these are you
have that imperative there is nothing
that you can do to shake that imperative
and so understanding how it works and
understanding how you need to meet the
needs of that if you want to be
fulfilled and be joyful is critically
important so as you go about teasing out
whether you have a self-care issue a
biological issue a self-esteem issue
something that is either we're not
addressing the imperatives to contribute
which is sort of the easiest one to go
to
or we've let the self-care get so out of
whack we're not sleeping we're not doing
all of those things that it's really
beginning to debilitate us from doing
the things that we need to do in order
to build up our self-esteem now your
self-esteem is really built around the
framework of congruence I said I was
going to do it I'm going to do it so
that when you say you're going to do
something you actually do it and then
whether that's a promise you make to
yourself or to somebody else and then
the
fulfillment formula which is to work
really hard to gain a set of skills that
are unique to you and matter to you or
exciting to you and that they serve not
only yourself but other people
and so if you're doing that working
really hard to get exceptional it's
something that matters that the world
cares about and that you love and then
you contribute in a way that elevates
you and other people that's the game of
fulfillment and so if you're doing that
I think you will find that that will
take care of self-esteem but if you're
not doing that if you're not finding
ways to contribute to the group if
you're not progressing in your life then
you're going to really struggle with
that so you do the self-care to make
sure that you can actually build the
self-esteem by contributing in that way
and then those two things work
wonderfully together but you have to
recognize that they really are two
separate issues and they both need to be
addressed I think it is very instructive
for people to ask the question who's
living my ideal life and that doesn't
mean who's making the most money it
means what person's life do you want to
live the real day-to-day grind of it and
when you identify what your dream job is
now we need to go about figuring out how
we get that job and so very quickly a
question about managing our ADHD and
figuring out how to stay focused
actually becomes a question of how do we
get good at finding the right job and so
if you think about
orchestrating your life and most people
live by the law of accident
I want to repeat that most people live
by the law of accident don't let that be
you right you bump into somebody they
know there's a job offering or it's
closer to where you live or it's you
know easier for you with the kids
whatever and so you bump into these
things it's like oh yeah cool oh I'll
make that little thing and instead of
designing your life you end up just
responding to sort of little bumps along
the road that end up leading you down a
path that was never a conscious choice
you want to sit down and map out okay we
know that we have we need a job that
meets certain criteria and one piece of
that criteria is that it allows you to
be very physical and get that energy out
okay so take control of your lives I
cannot stress that one enough journaling
is hugely important recognizing where
you thrive where you don't Thrive what
are deal breakers so it sounds like
eight hours behind a desk is a deal
breaker for you so map out those things
take very strict control of your life
and remember this may be one of of the
things that
that has led me to have a career a life
that
has certainly led to a tremendous amount
of joy in my life and looks like from
the outside
um impossible to obtain
I am an unreasonable person
and I set aside all of my
lacking elements all of my that's a
weird way to say inadequacies I set
aside all the things that I'm not good
at because I know it's all a process I
can get good at anything that I point
myself at right the only belief that
matters if I put time and attention to
getting good at this thing I actually
will get good at this thing so I just
set all of that aside okay cool yeah
whatever I'm not yet good enough to have
the life that I want my ideal life but
I'm going to get good enough and from
that I plant a very unreasonable belief
inside my soul which is I can have any
life I want
and now I just need to write out exactly
what that is I've hand crafted the life
that I desire and I know the realities
of who I am and what needs to be true in
order for me to
move well through the world right as
somebody who was diagnosed with ADHD as
a kid I fully get it and so I have
tailored my life to that momentum is
everything to me because I've got to
always be moving I've got to always feel
like I can
have tomorrow be wildly different than
today
but I take responsibility for the fact
that I have to build that
and it's not going to happen by accident
the life I would be leading if I led My
Life by accident would be radically
different it would not be tailored to
the things that I want so don't be
afraid to want
don't be afraid to spend an inordinate
amount of time thinking about what you
really want and then don't be afraid to
be unreasonable in accepting nothing
less when my voice coughs up you're just
not smart enough to pull this off I say
all right cool that's a habit Loop
trigger to remind myself that all that
really matters is skill acquisition have
I reached the limit of my ability to
acquire skills in the area that I need
to to move forward if the answer is yes
go hire somebody if the answer is no
then keep pushing my skill set because I
don't value myself anymore for being
smart so realizing that I'm never going
to be the smartest person that ever
lived sad but true that I just it
doesn't damage my sense of self-worth
and that becomes really important though
when you think about so always try to
tell people this
the point of life isn't money as
somebody who chase money for a very long
time I can assure you
won't touch how you feel about yourself
as much as you think it might so money's
not going to help you Fame isn't going
to help you accolades aren't going to
help you none of that is going to change
the one thing that matters which is how
do you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself that matters your entire
life is about that question and once you
stop valuing yourself for being smart
and you value yourself for this sincere
pursuit of greatness or Excellence or
just translating that potential into
actual skill set then
you know look you still have ups and
downs in life things are going to be
hard there's going to be emotional
turmoil all that but man can you get
back to Center really really fast what
steps can I take to bring my focus to
the one thing I'm working on while
blocking out all else
all right so the real key is you've got
to learn to compartmentalize so what I
do to begin my compartmentalization is I
create a list of all the important
things that I should be working on I put
that list in order this is very
important getting good at prioritizing
is an art form it is critically
important that you get good at that art
form and as you begin to break things
down and put them in order now you can
tell yourself hey this is what I should
be working on right now so rather than
trying to digest all the different
things that have to be done it's I'm
focused on this one thing right now and
my only job right now is to focus on
that thing and so by not letting your
mind wander and this meditation is very
good at bringing your focus back to the
breath which teaches you to bring your
focus back to whatever so I've got a lot
of things many things competing for my
attention but I know what my important
things are I'm working on the number one
thing right now let's say and so up this
is my entire world and if I find myself
wandering I bring myself back now part
of the reason that I can invest so
heavily in that is because I have the
belief that that's the most effective
way to work so since behaviors follow
beliefs you want to make sure that you
put that belief in place which is true
by the way that you can do everything
that you want to do just not all of it
at once so everything has to be done
sequentially you can't do everything at
the same time and this is why you have
to prioritize things out so if we know
that multitasking is actually a myth and
that you can put people in brain
scanners and what you're seeing people
who seem like they can multitask what
they're doing is called rapid switching
so they don't have what I have which is
high switching costs when I get in a
flow man I can go and go and go but if I
try to bounce back and forth between
things then I pay this high price and
inefficiency between the switching costs
of moving from switching from that task
to this task so I focus I stay on one
thing I have them in order I know what
I'm working on I remind myself that I
only have one job in that moment that is
to work on that thing I know that that's
the most efficient way to work and I
know that I'm good at prioritizing
things so it becomes very easy boom boom
boom and then you just hold yourself
accountable to actually doing that
practice makes perfect you might have a
difficult time in the beginning start
meditating if you need to to train
yourself to come back to the breath over
and over and over and then you can just
apply that to whatever you're working on
come back to the project if you have a
one million dollar business you'll get
one to get it to 10 million how what's
the best way to distribute your time
between marketing training your
employees developing yourself all right
everybody what does this start with
Clarity of your goal so what's your goal
10 million dollars a year that's just
money how are you going to get there why
are we are we just chasing money
sell drugs
you might go to jail but damn
on the way up baby
you can make some the next best thing
crypto
then flipping nfts but you can go broke
real fast doing that but damn if you hit
I made a hundred thousand dollars in 48
hours on a single nft that I bought for
250 dollars not Financial advice let me
tell you
but those are really dumb ways
crypto's not dumb but those are like
really sort of roll the dice better at
all on blackways if all you care about
is money it will send you down a very
dark path that I'm not super helpful at
once you have a goal and there's like a
thing behind you but even setting all
that aside I will just say you have to
be in an industry where the upside
potential is big enough that you could
actually solve a problem remember this
starts with I'm solving a problem for
somebody who knows they need that
problem solved and then I'm going to go
solve it better than anybody else that's
the real answer but if I could change
your life because this will matter so
much
business is a game of attrition most
people give up why do they give up
because hard things suck so when you
have a hard thing who has read Man's
Search for meaning by Victor Frankel
I want to is that really it scream that
out if you've read it
okay this is the the most important
thing I will say to you literally in
this whole talk every single person in
this room if you were serious about
enjoying your life
read Man's Search for meaning by Victor
Frankel it is about a guy who survived
the concentration camps he happened to
be a neuroscientist and what he realized
was you could predict when someone would
die within 72 hours because they would
lose a sense of meaning and purpose
now if you can survive Auschwitz on
meaning and purpose alone let me tell
you how important meaning and purpose is
in a business because as hard as
building a business has been it's no
Auschwitz
so trust me when I say meaning and
purpose will get you through when I was
building quests it was all about saving
my mom and my sister that was what I
attached to it
and so when I was there at 2 A.M on a
Friday night with bloody knuckles fixing
a piece of equipment that I did not want
to be fixing
I would think of my mom and my sister I
would not think of 10 million dollars
because Nature has compelled me to think
of them in a way and I get an emotional
reward I won't get from anything else so
even if you're just going to chase the
10 million make it about your kids
giving them a better life or something
but think about that other something
we good all right if something is really
high value really important the most
important thing you could be dealing
with then you're going to do everything
you can do to move that ball forward now
inevitably no matter what it is there
will be times where you will get to the
point where you need a break or there's
nothing more that you can do whatever
and so you're going to do everything
that you can do to push that ball
forward and then once you need to move
on for whatever reason then or you're
waiting for something then you go and
focus on the smaller things but don't be
afraid to say this is my number one
priority and so other things are going
to get less attention so one thing I
always tell people at impact theory is
doing less is always an option what's
not an option is hating your life okay
so we're not going to do things that
allow us to hate our life so if I know
hey I've got a health issue I have to go
really ham but I also have all this
knick-knacky [ __ ] that I have to
deal with
I'm going to take care of my health
first and foremost I'm going to cut out
things that don't have
you know anything to do with that
because they are less important to me
and we went through this with Lisa and
that meant that she was doing less at
work
um you know if you have to take paid
time off or whatever do it if you have
to take unpaid time off do it if you
have to scale your lifestyle back to
make sure that you can take unpaid time
off do it there are a thousand ways but
when something is truly the most
important thing then you need to address
it as such now what I find is everybody
tries to have these dueling competing
number ones they think that they're
supposed to be doing all of these things
at the same time I'm just here to tell
you that's not how it works so you have
to put things in rank order there is no
such thing as a dual number one priority
okay there is number one there is number
two three four five six so on and so
forth okay so line them up do them in
that order and you have to be relentless
about it and you have to accept that not
everything is going to get done as well
as you want to get it done but it should
get done in priority order
I find people have a really hard time
with that that one to me is a bit weird
if your priorities are listed in order
of the things that are important to you
why would you do them in any other way
unless you're lying to yourself about
what's actually important to you
so if what's really important to you is
what your parents think about you well
then you might start making stupid
decisions because you're not being
honest that what you really want is to
please your parents now once you start
being honest about what your priorities
are like for instance let's say you have
a health issue and you have kids and the
reality is that your kids are your
number one priority and your health is
number two
now what do you do
you've got a choice you either have to
de-prioritize your children which is
going to be hard for some people or your
spouse or your job or whatever but be
honest and if you're not prepared to
de-prioritize your kids then you have to
own that and accept the consequences
namely depending on what your health
issue is you may die younger than you
otherwise would because you're not
addressing it
this is where we got to be honest we
have to say what's really going on we've
got to say what our priorities really
are and when we stop bullshitting
ourselves about what our priorities are
then we can execute in priority order
and then everything in life gets clear
and simple doesn't get easy
but it gets clear and it gets simple
do it to it as my mom would say when I
really think about what's the impact I
want to have on the world is to show
people that it does not matter where you
are today it only matters who you want
to become and the price you're willing
to pay to get there and I it makes me
sad for other people that they think
that I have some natural talent and that
they then let themselves off the hook
because of that because let me tell you
when I was laying in bed four hours a
day every day in the morning
I didn't feel talented
I'll just tell you that like I felt like
a loser social media didn't exist there
was no way for me to reach out to people
and connect with these thought leaders
you could get Tony Robbins tapes and
books and stuff and that's what I did
but it's like man that's pretty Far Cry
from where things are today and so I I
felt so hopeless and so lost and just
unsure of how I was going to make
anything in my life and so for people to
be like
oh well easy for you to say you have XYZ
talents like really truly I do not I had
zero instincts as an entrepreneur coming
into it I was a buffoon fell on my face
embarrassed myself I'm just stupid
beyond all imagining how do you know
when it's time to refuel and choose
self-care instead of continuing to grind
physiological self-awareness is critical
I hear a lot of talk about people
developing psychological self-awareness
so understanding
um
what you're good at what you want to do
all of those things incredibly useful
but understanding how to read your body
may be even more important than that so
Lisa Feldman Barrett's book how emotions
are made detail the way that emotions
are far more of a bottom-up phenomenon
meaning they come from your body it
isn't you thinking about something and
then creating the emotion down that does
happen and of course you can spiral
yourself out of control simply by
thinking but usually what begins this
thinking process is a sense of unease
right anxiety is a bodily feeling
oftentimes disconnected from what you're
thinking so figuring out oh why do I
have the sense being able to process it
consciously we can pull it up into our
conscious mind and think through it with
words and logic but oftentimes it's
starting with that like oh man I don't
feel good about this and I don't know
why so this is the fascinating thing
about drugs is drugs can either
eliminate or change the bodily sensation
which then change is the story that
you're telling yourself about the
sensation now this isn't an
advertisement for drugs it's to get you
to understand that it can be risky to
sever the sense of body from what you're
telling yourself about it so you want
your body to give you this description
of what is going on but then as you take
conscious control of that to develop
that self-awareness around
physiologically what's happening you
need to understand why you're feeling
the way that you feel and so developing
that to get a sense of whether
this is a time to keep pushing through
or whether this is like one of those
moments where you actually really do
need to step back it's the difference
between sore muscles from you know a
nice hard workout and a torn muscle or
damage joint from an injury and the same
thing is true when you're thinking about
how hard to work how hard to push
yourself you need to figure out this
fatigue that I'm feeling this unease
this anxiety this stress is this a
natural part of pushing through the
difficulties of this project or is
something else going on this is now
really starting to cave in on me and
what I need to do now is take a step
back
meditate
Journal
hug my significant other pet my dog
cuddle my kids whatever the case may be
go for a run
but doing something that
slows you down
lets you take a deep breath
and the only way to figure that out is
to be able to interpret
the feelings that your body's giving you
into conscious thought okay and getting
good at that Loop is very very important
and it takes practice it takes
understanding what the body is
communicating why it's communicating it
what impacts it like what you eat and
drink has a huge impact on what your gut
is telling you and then your brain tries
to make sense of it and it doesn't
always go oh I'm feeling anxious because
in my case I was drinking a zero calorie
monster which much to my dismay because
I absolutely love them
make me feel anxious and so
getting an understanding of that
seeing that pattern was actually quite
transformational because I stopped
drinking them and my anxiety levels
plummeted by like 70 it's pretty crazy
didn't take me to zero but it made it a
phenomenon that was easily manageable
through meditation
so this is where you have to develop
that awareness that pattern recognition
and be able to say oh I feel this way
because of XYZ thing happening at work
or with my spouse or with food that I'm
consuming so be very thoughtful about
that and that will then help you
determine whether it's we need self-care
we just need to push through I get it I
get that humans do dumb things I get
that humans can be hurtful
I'm not interested though in what my
partner did wrong I'm only interested in
what I can do next time to avoid the
same mistakes without
diminishing the beauty that is a
relationship
now I have a fundamental belief that the
single greatest joy that anybody can
have in their life is to share a life
with somebody that they love and who
loves them that they trust and who trust
them
so I'm not going to give up on that
belief because it went wrong one time
two times three times whatever I'm
looking at what I can control to make
sure that I don't end up back in that
situation first and foremost we are
going to have to figure out what exactly
has happened
so
is it that you don't have a dream or
passion because you haven't taken the
time to
Define that because let me be very clear
passion is not
an archaeological dig
it's an architectural build
so you don't turn in words look inside
yourself and find this glowing Ember of
passion and excitement
that's been sitting there since birth
despite that some people will tell you
that that's how this works but it is not
if Steve Jobs were born a thousand years
ago he would not have dreamed of making
the iPhone what ends up happening is you
decide
there is something that you decide means
enough to you that you're going to
invest in it and then over time that
investment turns that thing into a deep
and abiding passion as you get better
and you get feedback from the world that
they value this thing that you're
getting better at
but it isn't just lying dormant within
you and this is like the number one
confusion that I encounter with people
is they think that
either they're broken and other people
were born with a passion and they were
not
or
they just think that
you know if I do enough introspection
I'm going to find something sitting
inside of me and finally my life will be
amazing
once you realize that in fact what
happens is when you look inside all
you're going to find are these Sparks of
Interest
and from that spark of Interest
through pursuing it as
process of gaining mastery
it will become a passion when you're
able to use that skill set that you
gained in the pursuit of Mastery to
serve not only yourself but other people
okay so doing that now you're in this
passion Loop of you worked really hard
you gained a set of skills allows you to
serve other people they give you
feedback oh my God thank you this is so
amazing I'm grateful for what you've
done build created given me whatever the
case may be and that feels good which
makes you want to go get better and
that's the passion Loop
now as you're doing that
you're able to really be energized by
the things you're doing
but it doesn't start by looking Inward
and finding something it starts by
realizing that you have to Fan those
flames of that spark of interest to turn
it into the Raging Inferno that you want
to feel of that passion but that comes
from that Loop
okay so that's the first thing to assess
now if you already have or had a passion
but this job has somehow beaten it out
of you that's a very different story and
so if that's what's going on we need to
figure out what is it in the structure
of that that is robbing you of that
what's going on exactly that's making
this overwhelming or stressful or not
fun is it politics in the office is it
just the work environment is too
fast-paced is it that you're not being
honest with yourself about you know
going back to this idea 50 of you is
hardwired fifty percent of you is
malleable if the hardwired part is out
of step with the life that you're trying
to lead there can be a lot of
frustration there so having the
self-awareness to understand did you put
yourself in the wrong position are you
trying to be Steve Jobs when you should
be Steve Wozniak that's a really
imperative thing to look at now I find
that a lot of times uh companies have
their own issues whenever you get a
large group of people together there are
going to be weird things that have to be
navigated but at the end of the day
while you can't control everything that
everybody does you can always control
how you react and so you can reorient
yourself within a company to figure out
one if there's a a path back to finding
that Joy but that comes from breaking
down what exactly happened that made you
stop feeling the joy and two are you
able to perform at a high enough level
that you're able to create the space for
you to get back on track because if
you're going to go in and try to move
things around and make some changes
within the company or within your role
or within how things work you're gonna
need to be performing at a very high
level to have the credibility to make
that ask and this is where it gets
difficult nobody wants to hear this I
get it everybody wants to point fingers
and say this is just a toxic company but
in reality if it's that bad leave do not
waste time start find another job first
I'm not just saying quit find another
job but get out of there don't act like
you're actually in prison you are not
actually in prison and yes I understand
that you have obligations and you may be
a single parent with kids and huge
responsibility I completely understand
and I have the most empathy for that in
the world but I want you to understand
you are only as trapped as you allow
yourself to be if you have a useful
skill set you will be able to find
another job and now is the time to go
looking for that while you're still
getting paid
now if you don't have skill set that's
marketable that's where we have to start
and so building up the skill set
so that we can be marketable somewhere
else that's going to give us the ability
to perform where we are or leave if it's
too toxic but assuming that we're going
to stay now we need that skill set to
perform at a very high level to create
the credibility to make the ask and go
to your boss or whomever is creating or
maybe not even creating the problem but
who has the ability to help you create
the solution now you go and say I'm
performing at a high level yes yes oh my
God you're amazing okay cool here are
the things that I would need to change
so often people's first instinct is just
peace out and they don't realize that
there are many things that they could
have done
to restructure the role to create more
space for themselves in order to stay
but what people end up letting happen is
they let themselves burn out and then
they want to leave and go somewhere else
not realizing that they will have the
same problem at the next job and instead
of doing the work themselves solving the
internal problem of how we ended up here
whether it's lack of skill set not
setting boundaries whatever the case may
be but keeping that ownership keeping
that responsibility recognizing that if
you make different choices you get
different outcomes so that you can go
ahead and change things there now again
if you want to leave leave by all means
take your skill set and go elsewhere but
make sure that you're not doing what I
was doing in my early 20s when I was
about to move to New York because I was
unhappy in LA and I thought the LA was a
problem in reality it was my mindset
once I changed my mindset suddenly I was
amazing
because it wasn't about la
it was about me and I thought ah like
something's got to change and so I just
wanted to go as far away as I could but
it wouldn't have solved the problem I
would have gotten to New York only to
have the same issue again and again and
again
I had to address my mindset and once I
did that then everything changed
so be very careful be very thoughtful
about
how you approach unwinding this problem
if you're always blaming other people
you're not going to get where you want
to go because you're not looking for the
things that you can do differently your
letting your psychological immune system
take over
make it other people's problems and then
you're not able to change
and once you realize that your life is
an exact reflection of your choices
now it's not so you feel bad it's so
that you remember if you make different
choices you get different outcomes and
so now you can make these changes or
gain more skills or whatever it is
that's needed to get the life that you
want now no matter where you go you will
feel completely comfortable that you can
shape things to your liking but you have
to know how the game works
you have to know that building skill set
is the key you have to know that
communicating with your boss what's
working what's not working and to have
earned the credibility to make the ask
do all that you'll have no problem
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the recent one-on-one
interview I did with Tom bill you check
it out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I was worth two
million dollars on paper and I'd never
been more unhappy in my life